Johanna class does gymnastics like a
young girl
despite being 91 years old she's even in
the Guinness Book of World Records as
the oldest competitive gymnast in the
world she's doing the bar exercise at
this year's gymnastics festival in
Berlin creating that company I'm nervous
before every competition my legs shake
and I have to take three deep breaths
before I can continue hi Matty Foust
admin Anton gates wheedle class used to
be a phys ed teacher later she became a
gymnast on the East German Olympic team
at 57 she returned to gymnastics her
physical fitness is a testament to her
great discipline
Dean's stuff when Donnell stuff it's
Tuesdays and Thursdays I go to the gym
Wednesdays we have a gymnastics group
for older people some of them are in
their 80s then I take a sauna
Friday I do gymnastics and go swimming
hello and I'm creating some swimming she
isn't just extreme about sports last
summer she jumped out of a plane to
honor British Queen Elizabeth who's the
exact same age as she is
at the gymnastics festival she always
meets old companions like a bee
grossfeld and Bruno Klaus from the USA
grossfeld is an American gymnastic
legend he's coaching his friend Bruno
who runs a gymnastic school for children
back home we don't have elderly people
doing gymnastics no we don't have a
competition for them so it's hard to
compare you know probably be similar if
they continue training but I'm amazed
with these people because they must go
to their club they turn frying and
practice at least a few times a week in
the summer time I do Giants for them and
they go crazy because I'm an old man a
lot of the kids can't do it even if
Johanna Cross has been doing this for
decades she sometimes gets dissatisfied
with her own demonstrations and at 91
she has a few minor ailments
when millennium pops done there's you a
headstand for a long time and then you
stand up then you can lose your balance
maybe I didn't practice it enough I was
never much good on the balance beam I've
done slaves this time instead of winning
like she always has in the past she came
in fourth place but there's one thing
you can take away from her she inspires
many people to get off the couch and
move their bodies
[Applause]